there's like stories where she's raising
funding and uh a guy leans over the
table and was like so why should I trust
you to be the CEO of this company and
she leans back over she goes because I'm
a complete and total animal and the guy
leans back and he's like all right I'm
in
[Music]
okay what's up we are here and I got two
little special announcements for you
first one
we got merch the boys got merch we're a
little late to the game we're a little
slow
uh most people start selling merch as
soon as they get a following took us
four years but Sam we figured it out you
got to sell t-shirts on the internet and
hoodies but that's I think that's all we
have uh well we'll add We'll add more
stuff but we have a few stuff it's
pretty stupid that neither of us are
wearing it today mine's in the in the
dryer at the moment again slow and
stupid yeah but yeah it's pretty cool we
have stuff that has some of our uh
favorite sayings and uh dude there's no
small boy stuff shockingly caught on
caught on in a big way I'll tell you
something I don't know if you listen but
I did an episode with Samir from Colin
and Samir and they basically are like
they're YouTubers that study other
YouTubers so they're like always
studying creators and he handed me two
things when he came to the interview he
handed me a newspaper did I tell you
about this no he handed me a newspaper
that was they made their own newspaper
Edition like one one edition special
edition for their like they hit some
Milestone so they printed them newspaper
and it was like
all of the like kind of content or
interviews from their show were like
it's like here's the here's the monthly
magazine or whatever here's the thing
for for our stuff dude let's do that
that's a great idea that's a great idea
it looked like a normal thing but they
they made it using their content and I
was like I love this he gave me one he's
like this is the last one we have I
don't know if that's true or not but man
you know how to make a boy feel special
when you say that uh the second thing he
handed me this hat that was a dope hat
that says uh press published it's like
this blue hat they have this super high
quality and I was like oh this is like
much higher quality than normal merch
and he goes oh yeah yeah here's how I
think about merch
he goes if you're Logan Paul or you're
Mr Beast you make consumables think
Prime energy drink it's a consumable I'm
selling this to you you're gonna drink
it use it whatever
and he goes uh Mr Beast chocolate he's
gonna or even Mr Beast merch just
t-shirts these are all just consumables
and he goes we don't make consumables we
make Collectibles he goes if you're a
Creator you should pick one of the two
paths and I love this Collectibles idea
he's like because what you want is you
want a way look you don't need to make a
you're not gonna make a fortune you
don't need to make a fortune through
your merch and which is why we've never
done merch because it's like I don't
know do we really care about making a
couple thousand bucks on t-shirt sales
never been that never been a motivated
for us
um
because we're rich if you missed that
part all right so the but the reason is
oh my God what a should we play it uh
like
is that the our new collectible like
douchebags R Us
going to a store near you
um but the Collectibles thing made total
sense to me where he's like you want the
people who are like kind of your your
thousand most but most like kind of
devoted people people who actually give
a [__] about what you do they're all
about what you're all about they think
the way you think they act the way you
act they're very similar to you they're
like for them this is like collectible
badge of honor so
make a limited edition number of units
um and when it's gone it's gone it never
comes back and on top of that you um
it's a signal so that anytime anybody
else sees them with that they know oh
they know you're part of the tribe they
know you're part of the tribe like if I
meet somebody uh Ben said this to me the
other day he goes he goes oh you know
what I like because he what he'll do
often is he'll talk to people who come
through my DMs or email us or whatever
he loves to go meet them and talk to
them and I'm like um that's great you
get a lot of energy from that I'm more
introverted don't like doing that as
much
um but he goes no it's he goes the
reason I like it he's like normally I
don't like just talking to strangers but
he's like if you like MFM there's like a
95 chance we're gonna be friends he said
because it's filters in people who think
the way we think and act the way we act
and like you got a sense of humor and
it's like you're not gonna like this
content if you don't if you're not a
business total business junkie and nerd
you don't like to nerd if you like don't
like to nerd about business you're not
gonna like this podcast and if you
like everything buttoned up and serious
you're also not gonna like this podcast
and so it's a great filter it's sort of
like when I see another grown man
drinking a glass of whole milk for
dinner you know what I mean like at
dinner like oh hey we probably have
similar values cheers
good good Catholic what's up uh so yeah
I feel that if you got a favorite flavor
of Skittle Sam Sam knows you're this guy
what's the second thing you have so um
okay that's the first prize second
surprise is Eclipse channel so this one
actually we should have done a long time
ago
um if you go to
clipmfm.com so this is our new clips
Channel
which is basically
you we do these podcasts about an hour
each clip of MFM does is it's a YouTube
channel for only the clips of the best
bits from the Pod clipped out for you so
that you can watch them in sort of like
three four minute bursts and for every
episode we're only pulling out the one
to three moments that actually mattered
so where somebody told a great story had
an amazing idea or shared something
about the the way their business works
are broke something down in a level of
satisfying detail and um at first I
wanted to Outsource this and then I was
like no [__] that I'm gonna hand curate
these clips myself because I'm like I
want the Channel that I would want to
watch because this is how I consume a
lot of podcasts like if you're like oh
do you like Lex Friedman yeah like it
love the pod great pod
I never actually watched the full ones
what do you search to find it if you
just go to clipmfm.com that'll take you
there or the you're gonna search my
first million clips and uh I tweeted it
out it's got like 700 subscribers now
but I need this to get into the tens of
thousands of subscribers because if you
listen to this podcast You're Gonna Want
to like why would you not want to just
get the best stuff faster uh or like in
a more simple way
um so yeah anyways that's my that's my
sales pitch for both the merch and the
uh the merches Collectibles limited
number of units and it's uh it's just a
way for our tribe to kind of signal to
each other hey this is what you know I'm
in the I'm in the club and um on the
other side we have the clips Channel how
did I do with my sales pitch that was a
great pitch and the skittlething joke
was very funny and you made me feel very
guilty because my why listen listen my
wife has her birthday is this Sunday and
I was gonna surprise her with a pinata
hopefully she doesn't listen to this
episode and I have a closet here in this
studio room that is where I've hidden
the pinata and I've also hidden tons of
bags of candy that I went and bought
from Party City
lots of Skittles on unfortunately I've
got to go back to Party City today
because I've eaten all the bags Skittles
so you nailed that one it's all they're
all empty there's a there's a a a whole
bunch of empty Skittle bags it looks
like a raccoon I went through that bag
that's not even like a small hole you
why did you need a face-sized hole in
that bag because when I do nighttime
eating I go into bear mode and I'm like
I'm like a bear getting like a like a
like a beehive you know I'm just like
I'm just like imagine just like using
your fists instead of your fingers
that's like what I am at Night My sister
says this thing to her girls like she
wanted them to like just go to their
room and take put themselves to bed so
she invented something called nighttime
sister playtime so that they would feel
excited about it's like oh do you guys
want to do nighttime sister playtime and
they're like oh my God yeah night time
sister playtime so they go to their room
by themselves they play and they fall
asleep and so I created nighttime Daddy
play time which is just when my kids are
gone and I get to just eat and be on the
internet and that's nighttime Daddy play
time and I celebrate it every single
night dude I like am like putting my
fist in a in a jar of peanut butter at
night like I'd wake up and there's like
bear claws all over the place so listen
I want to bring up a topic you put it on
your list and it's so funny you put it
on your list don't say what it is yet
but you put it on your list and I did a
ton of research on this topic and it's
incredibly fascinating so I want to tell
you about this all right we got to give
credit there's a reason we both have it
on our list someone tweeted at it they
did they go you should do it they just
said you should break down this
particular company and I was like that's
one of the very few times where I go
that's a great idea sir that's a good
one we're gonna do that so
let me tell you how it got started it's
super fascinating so there's this guy
named Steven Brill you have no idea who
he is but I bet you know Court TV he
started Court TV one of my all-time
favorites you know predecessor of cops
my favorite show of all time and uh it
turns into a huge success and then he
also starts American lawyer media which
is like a six or eight hundred million
dollar lawyer media company that he
sells so his next company it's called
verify identity pass it started in 03
after 9 11. and you want to come up with
an interesting way to make getting onto
a plane easier and safer he comes up
with this thing where it's like a credit
card and you could swipe it uh and in
order to like prove that you're I guess
not a terrorist something like that and
it gets you know a little bit of
traction he raises a hundred million
dollars to start this business he gets
uh 200 000 people to sign up
it flops doesn't work out
so uh there's this woman her name's
Karen I forget Karen's last name
actually but she's got this uh hedge
fund very successful hedge fund what are
you laughing at her name is anyone named
Karen I just always think damn uh what a
what a sideswipe they got in life by uh
by this this trend that just started
into whatever 2022 and all of a sudden
their name was never the same again she
spells it
c-a-r-y-n which somehow makes it better
to be honest I would too yes
like you know pronunciation change yeah
like how I call the uh La Quinta hotels
Laquita uh it's just a slight Rebrand
um so anyway she has this hedge fund
it's successful and all but she hears
about this company going out of business
and she's like you know this is actually
interesting and I think they made a
mistake they didn't brand it correctly I
think this should be more of a luxury
good company and so she buys the
business out of bankruptcy for six
million dollars then she goes on and
raises 50 million dollars and she
renames the company and she calls it
clear clear is that thing that a lot of
you folks see at the airport they are at
around 53 airports I think it's kind of
confusing at first when you see it
because you're like oh there's two lines
there's a TSA line there's a clear line
what the hell is going on turns out this
company is crazy successful and it
actually has a lot more implications
than I ever imagined so clear does
something like 600 million dollars a
year in Revenue market cap of three
billion dollars and what they do is they
built this technology at that stand
where it looks at your eye and it uses
Biometrics so it looks at your eye to uh
figure out who you are it looks at your
finger print and they like Fast Track
you in that line
but have you ever wondered how they like
get these contracts at these airports
it's like a monopoly yeah I don't know
how they do it so they give away 10 to
13 of their revenue uh to the airports
and what that comes out to be is
something like of their uh Revenue in
2019 they're doing like 350 million
Revenue they gave out 35 million dollars
to airports the most popular airport was
LAX that made them around 25 million
dollars in subscriptions of which they
gave 3 million back to LAX and so
they're kind of like in bed with the
government a little bit and they have
all these people and they're board who
are uh uh they took funding from Delta
and they have Delta Employees on their
board so like the head of Delta they
have like the former head of TSA
security on their board and it's crazy
fascinating because what they're doing
now wait but tip I was doing bad
listening because I was looking it up
while you were talking how did they get
into how what like what was the thing
that got them in because it's like seems
like once you're into the airport and
you're the you're the one
of course this is an amazing business
but what did they do today because in
what did she what was the miracle that
they pulled off there they promised
airports that they would give them a
percentage of the revenue so they would
open up a new Revenue stream and also
what they did was they took funding from
a couple Airlines and they on their
board they added like former head of TSA
and things like that and so like some
old-fashioned Gentleman's Agreement yeah
yeah so it's pretty fascinating what
they did but what's even crazier
hey Karen's actually pretty amazing
there's like stories where she's raising
funding and uh a guy leans over the
table and was like so why should I trust
you to be the CEO of this company and
she leans back over she goes because I'm
a complete and total animal and the guy
leans back and he's like all right I'm
in
and so they're but they're killing it
now they have 17 million users but
here's where it gets really interesting
what they're doing and I went and read a
bunch of their like annual reports it's
super fascinating and also scary what
they're doing is you can now sign in to
LinkedIn using clear so you can create
an account verifying your identity you
can also go to certain stadiums and buy
beer using just your your eyes and so
her whole theory is like look we're
gonna start with the airport but
eventually you're not going to use a
wallet anymore you might use Apple pay
for some stuff but for something that
involves your identity you don't need to
pull out your license anymore we're just
gonna look at your eyes and it's super
fascinating what these guys have pulled
off and I didn't realize guys I kind of
thought it was like a douchey company
because I'm like uh this is fifty
dollars for TSA for five years this
other thing is like 150 bucks for one
year why do I need this thing
but people still buy it I think I was
with you one time and you bought it you
even know what it was right well we were
late we were about to me and you were
about to miss a flight to Miami and so I
was like all right
MacGyver this line how do we do this
okay let me just sign up for Clear real
quick and see if we can jump the line
and it it worked you had TSA I didn't
have it and so uh I cleared my way in
and we we got on the plane it totally
worked and so it saves you just a little
bit of time but like what's crazy is
that uh their vision is huge and it
actually is like a super interesting
Vision that they have on how this
business can be can be much bigger than
it is now and it just like goes way more
in depth than I ever thought yeah I'm
not sure I'm a Believer in the rest of
that Vision because like I don't care uh
like
the amount of effort it would take for
the you're at a ball game and you want
to buy a beer and now each beer vendor
is going to buy Hardware to uh scan my
retinas and I have to stand still for
seven seconds while it scans my eyes
just to verify my age like it feels like
that's not the right payoff like the
airport one makes sense because it's
like hey look airport security it's a
big deal okay you can skip this line and
if you're a business traveler you're
gonna miss a flight those are high
stakes that's important and so it seems
like the right payoff to kind of like
work ratio I wonder where else that
really exists where you actually need to
on the spot verify your identity so last
summer
um a new law was enacted and so right
now if you live in I believe it's
Virginia and you go to pornhub.com or a
bunch of other porn sites yeah go for it
uh I see you typing
interesting interesting website
this one so there's a new law enacted
that for people in Virginia you have to
verify your identity in order to go to
certain on websites to prove that you're
over 18. and so it like brings up like a
camera where it wants to take your
picture from your computer lens to like
check your identity shame you it just
starts shame with your headphones it's
like Game of Thrones
yeah like the Avatar is like a it's like
a nun holding a rosary and uh she's like
are you sure
um but uh but like there's like a few
instances where this actually is
interesting by the way those porn
companies uh some of the thing that
they're doing is they're putting it on
they're they're making it so if even if
you're outside of Virginia some porn
websites are still making you register
in order to like make you pissed off at
the Virginia congressman who approve
this so you like they should put it all
down which is hey Mark Ingram in
Virginia is forcing you to open your
eyes and get scanned before you watch
porn if you feel any kind of way about
that push this button well they even
have like a Gmail login for some of
these porn it's just it's weird it's
weird is what it is uh but like I uh
it's crazy but there are a few instances
but the most crazy thing about clear is
like this is a total Monopoly uh that
they have in airports and I'm shocked
that they've had this I don't know
anything about public valuations it
seems potentially like an undervalued
company what is it valued at and what
was the revenue again it's in the five
or six hundred million dollar range they
claim they have 90 retention so it's not
like as good retention as software but
it looks like uh their market cap as of
today is three billion dollars I mean
that's kind of an amazing like a three
billion dollar company that does such a
simple thing and you said they're only
in like 63 airports or something like
that that's that's crazy that it's so so
big with such a small footprint and it's
such a simple product uh very impressive
yeah they're in uh 53 airports in uh
their their the trailing 12 months
they've done 530 million dollars in
Revenue
wow that's impressive uh here's a random
related uh startup did you ever see this
company called evolve they uh they make
metal detectors no so their big thing
was they're like uh it's one of these
businesses like one of the meta
takeaways of this podcast is all the
businesses are hidden in plain sight
they're right in front of you and if you
just start once you start paying
attention you're like oh this didn't
just get here who put this metal
detector here there's a company that
does this how do they work
um is this the same company at all of
these places how did they get that
contract and so metal detectors are at
every big venue right
um you know stadiums concert for whether
it's for concerts or Sports airports
that sort of thing and so there's a
company that had raised money from Lux
uh Lux Capital like a VC firm that does
like whatever slightly hard tech or hard
tech um and what these guys did was they
were made of metal detector good pitch
for them they do I don't know whatever
well I was gonna say like Cutting Edge
hard tech and then I was talking about
[Laughter]
slightly hard stuff
yeah harder than e-commerce so they
um
but their actual demo is pretty cool so
what they're doing is it's a metal
detector that can let you just walk
straight through much faster so like you
don't need to I think it's like you
don't need to like
um take you don't need to take out
everything for your pockets and you
don't need to
um like you know like I guess like it
could just detect it faster so the flow
of traffic is faster than a traditional
metal detector
um
and that's kind of just crazy to me that
that's like such a simple idea that I'm
like oh yeah I guess like
I guess that's true like if somebody
just made a better metal detector going
forward they're going to win a bunch of
contracts all right I got to tell you
about one thing that's one of the great
joys of my life and I'm not a cars guy
I'm not a watch guy but there's one
thing that gives me a lot of joy and
that is having a virtual assistant uh
you know here's the scenario I'm running
my companies and even though I'm
supposed to be this uh CEO we all know I
spend 20 30 of my time just doing random
[__] stuff that is not high value
but it's just tedious the stuff that has
to get done
but it's not creativity doesn't require
me and it doesn't add a bunch of value
to the business it's just stuff just
stuff that has to get done and so that
stuff is what a virtual assistant does
like just this week alone you know I
lose my wallet so she goes to the DMV
website fills out a bunch of forms gets
me a new license or um you know every
morning people have their morning coffee
I have my morning metrics and my morning
metrics are basically all the business
metrics that I care about compiled she
goes she finds them for all the
different sources puts it in Excel sheet
takes a screenshot text it to me so that
when I wake up in the morning I don't go
on Twitter or check my email I'm looking
at what are what are the metrics at and
what do I need to do I'm focused on the
right things so having a virtual
assistant is a no-brainer whether it's
travel booking email inbox or just
knocking stuff off your personal to-do
list that would have just lingered there
forever
um I think it's a no-brainer if you're a
business owner you should definitely do
it
um I think one of the best places to
find a assistant is Shepard so go to
support shepherd.com you know I pay my
assistant I think eight dollars an hour
something like that that's double what
she was making in her previous job so
it's a win for her and for me it's super
affordable it's something that you know
you don't need to have the biggest
business ever be the biggest big shot in
order to afford it so it's amazing I now
do this for my CEO and my cm02 like I
just give them assistance without them
even asking because I know it makes them
more productive that's it does that for
me so of course it's going to do that
for them too so go to sportsshopper.com
check them out
um get an assistant and tell them I sent
you they'll take good care of you if you
do that so supportshopper.com check it
out I have this thing called qriket I
want to tell you about they spelled this
funny do you know what this is by the
way have you have you ever have you ever
heard of a Cricut Machine no so it's c r
i c u t no what is that okay yeah uh Ari
new producer Ari is here by the way
first episode so if you uh if you like
how this produce this episode's going if
you like how it's edited credit to Ari
if you hate this episode blame on Ari
alright so all right have you ever heard
of this machine the qriket machine
I have not okay this is It's a DIY like
home crafting machine it's 20 years old
this company makes a billion dollars a
year in Revenue 100 million dollars of
free cash flow a year Sam how does that
sound I like the sound of that and what
it is is it's basically a cutter so you
put in some material it could be plastic
could be a sticker like paper and then
it'll cut the shape for you so you can
do like die Cuts Like sticker or
whatever by the way I barely understand
how this works so I'm gonna put you yeah
I'm I'm looking at it now it looks like
a printer but I guess it's like a
printer but it's more for cutting than
from printing yes so it's basically a
way to cut different shapes of things so
you want to put something on a water
bottle you want to make a label you can
cut it using your Cricut home Home
Credit is this an invention that they
made or was this a style and is this
like a Kleenex tissue type of thing no
it's more like
um when Steve Jobs like I want you know
every uh Bill Gates or whoever was like
you know every home was gonna have a
personal computer it's like you know a
computer on every desk and that's
basically what these guys did so there
was like these machines were there
before for for you know for people for
industrial application and then this the
company that started it was called like
Provo Craft or something like that they
were making these machines for craft
shops so you would take your design to a
craft shop and you'd say hey I'd like
you guys to cut this for me this way and
they would have the machine on the on
the countertop to cut it for you because
you're not gonna have your own machine
these are expensive what these guys did
was they made it smaller and made it
more affordable so that people could
just have these at home and um
and so you know if you go look at Etsy
you go look at things like this a lot of
those people know all about the qriket
machine because they have them at home
and they use it to make their goods so
how do they cut your name out in this
cool looking font they don't do it by
hand they have a qriket machine that
will cut it for you and so just an
incredible business and
um I saw I heard about this because we
were looking at an investment so we're
looking at investment from some of the
original guys who were early there and
they've spun off and they're doing like
a new a new like better version of the
qriket machine and I'm like yeah I just
don't know how big this space can be
he's like well I think it's gonna be
bigger than Cricket which does a billion
dollars a year and is spinning off 100
million free cash flow and you know as a
public company and I was like oh okay
yeah yeah so uh my bad and he's he was
telling me some pretty incredible things
about The Crafting community so he's
like
you know stores like Michael's
um they he goes Michael's if you go read
their kind of like uh you talk to their
leadership or read their earnings or
whatever he's like Michael's believes
that every single person who walks
through their door is an Etsy seller
their default assumption is that if you
come to a Michael's you are going to
sell on Etsy and because it's like more
the majority than the minority which is
kind of amazing and Etsy is this
obviously this Marketplace to go sell
your goods but if you look okay if
that's how you sell your goods well then
how do you make them underneath that and
so I am very tempted to invest in this
uh space because it is such a big space
what's the product too
um I don't want to give it up uh just
because it's that kind of proprietary
but it's like something like Cricket
something like Cricket but better it
does more things so the qriket just cuts
this does other things in addition to
cut got it so um now this came by the
way through our buddy Al Doan so if you
go back and listen to the episode with
Big aldone Al and his mom start a
company in the quilting space
um and the little breadcrumb trailers we
have Patrick Campbell on the podcast
Patrick Campbell runs a payments company
called profitwell and we were like hey
you see the payments of like lots of
companies like any cool Trends in the
payment space that we wouldn't have
thought of he's like quilting and we're
like what he's like quilting is enormous
it's like cool thing like the grandma
hobby is it yes enormous there are
companies that do blah blah blah so he
told us about that afterwards I get a DM
from aldone he's like hey I'm one of
those companies that we make hundreds in
100 million plus a year and my mom you
know Jenny Jenny Doan or whatever
started this business and I joined her
and like yeah we sell
like kind of crafts for Quilters like
little squares right it's like the
packages the squares the fabrics and
they do like a daily flash deal it's
like oh here's the quilting thing of the
day and like that's how they do it so
they built this huge thing to the point
where he now bought a small town and he
turned it into like the mecca of
quilting it's a Disneyland for quilting
the Disneyland for Quilters it's like if
you're a quilter and you want to take a
trip to like indulge in your hobby this
is where you go and I'm like wow this
guy's thinking big I love this guy he's
a funny guy and so he was talking about
quilting and then he introduced us to
this deal he's like yeah I'm investing
in this thing because I'm in this Craft
Space and I you know this is like one of
the best kind of Concepts we could do
here
so I'm just getting I'm just scratching
the surface on like this space I know
nothing about but I'm very fascinated by
this I wanted to share that with you
dude the Etsy platform is wild have you
looked into like how big some of these
sellers are my mother-in-law started an
Etsy store and she's making hundreds of
thousands of dollars uh selling pillows
on Etsy right and one of the cool things
about Etsy is you can go to the store
and it'll show you how many lifetime
sales how many transactions have
happened at that store it's visible on
every profile yeah and you'll like look
up something very obscure and you'll see
that they've sold 50 000 versions of
whatever their whatever they have it's
wild how powerful Etsy is by the way I
believe this is how Moy started made of
deodorant so I think the like public
stories like my sister got pregnant and
I was concerned for her health and I
wanted her to have aluminum and
paraben-free deodorant I interviewed him
about this the real story is what
basically he was just looking I think he
was like maybe I'll do mattresses a lot
of people are buying mattresses this is
right when Casper was getting going and
he called that so he's like yeah
mattresses and then he's like [__] these
are heavy this is hard to ship I don't
know if there's like a lot of repeat
buying on this and then he randomly came
across a lady selling uh chemical free
deodorant on Etsy he ordered that and
then he ordered like five or ten other
ones and he asked everyone in the office
like put this under your arms how's this
feel and it like some of it was good and
he's like some of it was was bad but he
found one that was great and he goes hey
lady can I uh slap a native label on
this and we just resell your stuff and
that's how it starts and then eventually
he gets big and gets traction he's like
all right now we're gonna make our own
thank you very much and I think I think
she helped him like formulate it and and
she couldn't keep up with the demand she
was like dude I don't I'm not trying to
scale this to this level like I'm you
know my fingers hurt sir like you know
can I can I take a break here and um she
was like how about this how about I buy
the formula he's like how about I buy
the formula off you and you help me
figure this out then we'll we'll bring
this to a manufacturer because we've
outgrown your scale now like yeah and
then and then after two years he sells
the business for 100 million dollars in
cash and he that was like you know I
think the business probably does like
200 million a year in sales so you could
argue it was early but I think he turned
out all right but he like sold the
business like right before maybe two
years three years before like the whole
DDC thing was like all right this is
more challenging than we thought but but
one of the insights was this is I think
it I think natural deodorant was one of
the top selling products on Etsy and
that's why he he had Market validation
that there's something here aluminum
free deodorant I think this is not like
him and many other people do this where
like you know the business has this this
um you know touching
origin story this is this wonderful
backstory but like these are often you
know reverse engineered later
um you know the that's not how a lot of
these businesses work one of my fun
things is like let's just be honest not
this podcast and like say what it is uh
you know like I started it like started
the milk road because I was interested
in crypto I saw what you did with the
hustle and I was like oh I get it I
could do that and I just did that with
uh with milk hustle for crypto and it
just like went down that road and did it
and my goal was to make a business I
made a bunch of money right like that's
the that's the thing and I thought oh
cool doing this I'll learn about a bunch
about crypto that's my TR that's the
transparent story there wasn't like some
some origin story where you know my
cousin needed and then it hit me and
then it hit me I should just write this
email for my cousin you know and and I
didn't stop there I decided you know
let's just open up for friends you're
all my cousins yeah exactly yeah
and so like I think you could do that
again on Etsy I think you could always
go back to Etsy and look for top selling
products and use that as inspiration for
uh for thinking you know for boys I'm
sure I don't know this but like I'll put
a guess out there which is that like an
arranged marriage he had a checklist
he's like what is under one pound for
shipping what is a recurring purchase
that's consumable what is something that
has a you know uh differentiation
against a big Market but has a unique
differentiator like natural deodorant
that's chemical free versus what Old
Spice and these other guys were doing
and like he had a checklist and he's
like oh good deodorant lightweight you
know um review purchase with a clear
differentiator got it by the way these
qriket machines are awesome I'm I think
I might get one of these uh these are
sick they're expensive they're like a
grand promo code Sean craft at checkout
for uh you know 10 cents off these are
awesome it does a good find I mean it's
not like it was like some like a rare
thing but it's rare to us I guess but it
is a good find yeah this is out of our
bubble
um for sure
I invested at this company
that does this for um for bathrooms and
so they they make women's like hygiene
products they're like tampons pads that
go in um that go into uh like the
vending machine it's installed on the
wall and so uh it's just like a better
uh a better version of um of what used
to be there there's always something
there and it was just like kind of
looked like something a janitor designed
and then they just made like a really
beautiful version of one that was easier
to use more friendly just look cleaner
like looks more hygienic and then what
happened is that every state started
enacting laws saying that hey yeah every
woman's restroom needs to carry these
products just like you you know you have
toilet paper whatever you need to carry
these products and so state by state
this is rolling out and what they're
doing is they're going
state by state into
um
uh into these uh stadiums or schools
universities and they're getting these
multi you know multi-million dollar
contracts for installing their thing and
once they're installed they're not going
to take them out it's sort of like clear
it's like these little monopolies that
you can you can get if you're the right
product in the right place at the right
time with the right sales pitch because
once it's installed I don't think
they're ever going to go uninstall these
things and change vendors because
somebody has a slightly nicer design is
that company working uh yeah like I mean
I haven't seen I can't share their like
numbers right away
um it's like those disgusting baby
changing stations what are those called
kangaroo or Jack or something yeah yeah
exactly those are filthy
yeah uh her name's Claire coder she's
very like uh she's a very strong uh like
leader kind of personality type person
and so she she does a great job like
she's on LinkedIn she's like super
active with it
um it's called the company by the way is
called Aunt Flow and so uh has like a
more more uh you know friendly name
versus like what was there before and
what she described kind of like what the
process was before versus after
um you're like oh I get it and I get why
other people haven't attacked this space
because if you know most of the VC
funding is going towards men a lot of uh
Founders who are trying to start these
Venture skill companies are men they're
not even aware of this issue never even
been in the bathroom they can't you
wouldn't even know that this problem
exists uh but she's done an amazing job
of like identifying the problem and then
building a like super uh like
uh just a likable brand and a likable
story where it's like if you could
choose between the default alternative
or this like you'd obviously pick this
that's cool I got pitched on a bunch of
those I passed on all of them because I
don't know but like that that sounds
good that it's working hopefully it
makes up money I mean getting those I
when I saw I was like I don't know man
selling like two dollar things in the
bathroom it can that be a big thing but
you said they're getting million dollar
contracts who pays for it the facility
the facility has to has to do that like
the facility needs to stock uh this
product and it's a recurring thing right
they install the dispenser for let's
just call it like 500 so it's 500 to
install the dispenser and then you're
every you know every month or every
quarter you're gonna like have to do
refills and again that thing's gonna sit
on the wall forever uh it's not gonna go
anywhere and so to me this is like
owning a piece of real estate in all
these that's gonna pay you rent and I
think that that's just like I don't know
if this becomes like a 10 billion dollar
company you know that that's like
different Next Level stuff but it's
clear that this is a defensible business
clear that it's going to have recurring
Revenue it's clear that
um well there's a lot of facilities out
there and they're all going to have
women's restrooms multiple of them per
building and each one of those is going
to need to have this in it so you start
to add up pretty quick
foreign
[Music]
have you heard of HubSpot see most crms
are a cobble together mess but HubSpot
is easy to adopt and actually looks
gorgeous I think I love our new CRM our
software is the best HubSpot grow better
okay so let me tell this story you know
actually these guys much better than I
do I only know it's secondhand but I'm a
fan of this so
back in the day when you were doing the
hustle one of the very first things
before I knew you one of the very first
things you created was this infographic
about a business that I found
fascinating and it was a business called
I cracked and I think what you were
doing was you were trying to sell uh
tickets to your conference he was a
speaker and yeah and you're a genius you
were like okay instead of saying come to
my conference buy tickets you said
look at this incredible story of I
cracked these guys were in their you
know whatever college dorm room uh AJ
and Tony and they realized that
smartphones are taken off and so they
decide hey everyone else is building
apps let's just try to fix people's
cracked phones because there's the more
cell phones there are there's more crack
phones there's gonna be and they made
this like on-demand service so if you
crack your phone same day they know
that's a big problem for most people
same day they'll come to you grab your
phone and fix your phone and it had this
crazy NPS score and it starts scaling
they get to like I think in the first
um
you know they only raise 500k and they
get to seven and a half million in uh
revenue and you write this you make this
great infographic and I'm like this
one's in the infographic hating
infographics were like the thing back
then were they you were the only one I
saw it do with them but they were great
you and uh what's his name John I think
he was their design he was the design
guy you guys did an amazing job it's
just you two doing the hustle
um and so
and then you what you did was you're
like love the story want to hear more
stories like this in fact want to hear
AJ tell this story himself he's speaking
in the house of Khan in three weeks buy
your ticket and then you know I didn't
one I'm not just gonna buy a ticket but
you would release one every what like
week or so uh yeah one a week one a week
and by the third week I was like damn I
love these stories I don't all right
I'll go to this conference like sounds
like it sounds like these are great
stories and so I went to hustlecon
when I met you and you know this story
uh you know happy has a happy ending so
these guys okay so let me finish their
story now because they're what they're
doing is pretty interesting so they go
they what they realize is okay we people
are gonna have crack phones we need to
scale and they scaled through colleges
so they're like they looked at this
business like uh itech I guess which is
like you know sort of like a Geek Squad
type thing and they were like all right
um
basically we just need to copy paste
what we're doing to like uh actually I
don't know if I take was the company
They're copying or that's what they
called their people but like they looked
at like how to scale this they figured
it on one college campus it's like okay
we need these Runners we're going to be
able to cover this radius and repair
these phones this way and then just copy
pasted it across college campuses and
they basically they they taught college
kids how to repair phones and icrack
would send them the leads and they're
like all right you got to go show up at
this guy's house you're gonna charge
them 300 it's all done the phone you get
100 we get 200 whatever it was something
like that it's a sort of scale they
blitzed and in 30 days they were on 28
college campuses which is amazing they
had booted up 28 campuses in 30 days
which I love uh they get into YC they're
one of the only non-technical teams to
even get into YC and it's because this
hustle was like obviously very appealing
and um and so at one point they even buy
like uh 200 smart cars that they like
wrap in their eye cracked logo and they
give to their eye techs and they're so
they're all running around San Francisco
fixing iPhones and [__] it was pretty
cool and then I was like okay so how did
you scale from there they go well we
started using SEO and press and they're
like we realized that the Press loves to
talk about the following headline 24
year old making millions doing relatable
thing and it's like he's like started
out of his college college dorm room and
they're just doing something that all of
us need repairing your cracked phone and
these 24 year olds say they're making
millions and so they just took that
story and they did it at the local level
so these Cincinnati uh you know the
Cincinnati uh this guy grew up in
Cincinnati he's making millions other
guy grew up in wherever he's making
millions whatever College they went to
they did it locally there
um and oh they just booted up at this
college campus and they did it locally
then they did it nationally and they
started stack so that when you searched
fixed cracked iPhone they could show up
organically at the top through SEO from
these high Authority Publications that
were writing puff pieces about them love
it so these guys are great now here
comes the problem
they're they've only raised 500k they're
at 7.5 million it's profitable business
is growing fast
they never announced this but they go
and they raise 50 million dollars to
scale the business
and that 50 million gets them to go
International and at Peak they get to 36
million in run rate but it's just
getting harder and harder to keep the
group to keep up with the growth monster
and the growth monster is demanding that
they get to 100 million in Revenue
because you raised 50 million that means
you got to go huge you've you've cut off
your options and so they just couldn't
do it and they just could not scale the
business beyond that and they end up
selling it to Allstate yeah insurance
company and so they that one of the guys
he stays there for three years he earns
out
uh his deal and he decides all right
after year three I'm gonna quit start my
next company and that takes us to Cloud
poker night I used it
for Hampton or what'd you do yeah well
we tested it I was a beta user and it
didn't quite work out when we start when
you would be a beta user I am beta
they called the right guy we need a
baiter yeah
it was a little rough when we first
started because it was only a few weeks
in but I think now he like nailed it and
it was actually really fun so I want to
do two things I want to show the home
page because
I love what they wrote as the landing
page the copy on this homepage have you
been to it it's so good read it read it
off so it says poker is the new sport
for business Minds golf is yesterday's
news request access and then there's a
photo
it's a cute dealer dealing to uh that's
Anthony's wife that's the Founder's wife
doing okay great by the way cute dealer
um so so and then there's like whatever
people playing and you can get a demo of
the product so super strong Landing uh
landing page then you scroll down it
says business Minds who love poker so
just think about the positioning so
almost everybody would be like
online poker night right cloud-based
poker for you know poker software right
like this is like the generic shitty way
to Market this but instead they not only
say the benefit of it they go even
bigger they just say big picture
golf is the old way poker's the new
sport for business people that's the um
that's the we don't sell Saddles we
don't sell Saddles here here uh Mantra
like when Stuart Butterfield created
slack he wrote this great memo if you've
never read it go read it it's called we
don't sell Saddles here and he's like
look guys we made slack we know it's
awesome now our job is to teach the
world that this is awesome here's the
problem
most people you talk to that run a
company are not in the business for chat
software they're not looking for a team
chat tool it's just not a thing they
even do they're not even looking for it
so even if we say we're the best team
chat software doesn't matter they don't
care they're not into it he's like
Lululemon made you want to do yoga to
live the yoga lifestyle and he's like we
need to do the same thing we need to we
need to sell instead of selling Saddles
and saying we make the best Saddles we
need to sell the joy of horseback riding
and then when they once they fall in
love with the idea of horseback riding
they're gonna say where do I get a
saddle and we're gonna say we provide
yeah we sell the best Saddles and so
same thing here I love what he's doing
by saying poker is the new sport for
business people
um that's the that's the selling the
dream and then okay how are we gonna go
play poker use our software and they all
they they have all these like quotes
about uh you know successful people who
have played poker and I I recognize a
few of these people there's Warren
Buffett there's Sam Altman there's Paul
Graham Peter Thiel and look at that
there's the chairman of the milk road is
out there
uh that's you're on there and I have no
idea
I'm on the page two of the carousel if
he swipes I never got that far but what
they did was they go business mind's
love poker then it's a quote and it says
which leader said this Warren Buffett
chamoth or Paul Graham and you're like
oh that sounds like chamoth uh nope it
was Paul Graham okay cool and then it
shows you another one so again
uh using sort of the the people you
already trust to say that poker they're
not saying Cloud poker night is great
but they're saying poker is the best is
the sport for business people
um and then it's why poker's so great
blah blah blah and then it says why you
should use our software which I love so
I think this landing page is amazing but
you have to explain how it works so
basically well I mean I've used it so
what it is is you uh we're gonna use it
for Hampton and we're still going to but
we did it for a team night and the way
it works is it's almost like Zoom meets
poker so they have like a professional
setup and in my case when I use it it
was Anthony the founder he's got this
like home setup that's a that's a card
table and then there's a camera on him
and you see him dealing the cards and
you see him talking to you and
interacting with you and you could see
all your other teammates also playing
but he puts the cards over another
camera of which only you your you know
the user you see your own card so it's
really like live poker uh and there's
even a dealer who's like shooting [__]
with you and like asking if you want to
hit it it's really fun it's very
interactive it's awesome I think it's a
great business idea uh for a bootstrap
business I love this idea
um
yeah I love poker I played poker I I
really I think there's a cool idea I
would love to do an MFM version of this
so like that's a great idea I mean hold
on I think they did make one for us so I
asked the guy this morning I go hey this
would be amazing I don't like the live
shows we did were cool because we got to
meet people who listen to the pod that's
awesome
but I don't like traveling like leaving
my house and so this is great because we
get to play poker we get to be on camera
meet other people who are
um listeners to the show and we can just
host our own tournament and so I think
he's gonna do uh
cloudpokernight.com MFM so that there
will be a uh uh something there he says
to to uh RSVP for this so if anyone
wants to play in a poker night we should
do that with people who listen to the
Pod I think they'll do that'd be kind of
Amazing by the way the other founder so
you talked about Anthony Anthony Martin
he's one of the co-founders of icracked
the other co-founder AJ he's one of my
great friends he's a crazy person he's
one of the wildest people I've hung out
with his other company or his new
company that he started it's a
they call it uh like one headline called
it the Tesla for chicken coops so if you
go to coop.farm it's a smart Chicken
Coop and he like he's into like
beekeeping and he's always had chickens
and animals and [__] like that so he
made a smart Chicken Coop that like
opens the doors automatically and feeds
the chickens automatically it's pretty
funny
um I almost invested in it but I'll
explain one of the reasons that made me
nervous is that like the day or a few
weeks or something like that before the
round closed when the Ukraine thing
happened AJ went to Poland for like a
month and was a volunteer helping like
Ukrainian refugees and uh the guy's
crazy is he Ukrainian no he just is into
that [__] he just does wild [__] all the
time like I'll be hanging out with him
and he's like he used to boat to work
yeah he he lived right near uh Oracle
and the office his icracked office was
in Redwood City but it was across this
little Bay and he would take this little
boat to where work but every once in a
while they had offices in Soma and he
would ride his this is like a small boat
literally fit two people he would ride
this little boat 20 miles up the bay to
Soma and Doc is both there uh the guy is
crazy you would do crazy no and when I
say boat I remember you told me that
like a decade ago and I still remember
you were like yeah my friend he's
kayaking to work by the way the boat's
not the best word uh it's better to
describe it as a jet ski that you stand
up on so like he would jet ski to work
basically no that's what this thing was
so was he paddling or it was a motor no
it had a motor it had a motor and he
would like a motor it was like a jet ski
he was like he was like Kenny Powers he
would like jet ski to work uh his the AJ
is crazy he's uh he's a crazy person
this raised a bunch of money from Peter
Thiel yes yeah they raise money for
Peter teal he's like Peter I see you're
crazy and I raise you
[Laughter]
Peter chicken coop
it's a weird business but I think it
could work
yeah that's amazing
um so I think this is a really cool
business I want to see uh how this goes
I actually want to invest in this I wish
I could own a piece of this and uh just
host poker nice because one of the great
things about businesses like this is
um the virality so I'm very interested
in products that can grow virally and
most people get this wrong products that
grow virally are not products that
succeed through Word of Mouth like if
you talk to a normal person oh yeah it's
spread virally people used to go tell
their friends because they loved it so
much no no that's called Word of Mouth
viral is literally like the word sounds
it's like a virus you you're not even
trying to get it on other people but it
gets on them they catch it from you so
like the classic example of this was
Hotmail
um at the end of every email it was
signed like you know sent through
hotmails you know sent with love through
Hotmail or something like that so you
weren't trying to tell somebody hey you
should start a Hotmail account but it
was added to every email as almost like
you know a little virus that was
attached to the email that basically
said
sent through Hotmail get your free
account today and so people started
signing up and had this crazy viral
coefficient and products like Cloud
poker night have a different kind of
virality
which I think I don't know what it's
called but group virality or something
um similar to how Eventbrite grows or
meetup.com grows which is an attendee
becomes a host so a host creates an
event naturally they need to invite a
bunch of other people because that's how
an event works and then you might be in
the 100 people that attend some event
and if you liked that experience the
next time you're thinking about hosting
an event you'll go use that same product
because you got sort of it was incepted
into your brain through somebody else so
I think the same thing will happen here
what I would want to do is I'd want to
host a bunch of these for fun using the
MFM Community but then guess what the
MFM Community when they have a good
experience as a player would then host
if there could be a team bonding night
or their corporate events or sales sales
events or whatever
um for their businesses and I think
that's how these businesses can grow
yeah I think it's cool what's uh what
what do you want to do Cricket crit cut
or gamer dating idea I'll do the gamer
dating okay so um
Sam here's why you should date a gamer I
know you're married but if you could go
back
here's why you should have dated a gamer
and me too my wife she doesn't play any
games
um I just bought a PS5 hoping that maybe
that would sway her she instead just got
upset so here's why you should date a
gamer you're not a gamer are you
I'm like the least gamer gamer I'm in
the club but just barely I'm by the door
by the end I'm by the exit door I played
Call of Duty last night for like the
first time in a year it's impossible
these kids are talking it's so difficult
I'm unbelievably so it sucks also
all the popular games now they're like
pubg it's like yeah you jump out of an
airplane I'm like oh wow that sounds
exciting and then it's like you land and
now you just sort of walk around look
like you live in 20 minutes and then
you're not gonna see anybody during that
whole time you're just gonna be
collecting supplies I'm like okay cool
but for what it's like because then when
you do see someone I'm like but I never
see anyone like yeah that's the problem
you're just gonna get shot in the head
and it's gonna start again and it's like
these games where nothing happens it's
crazy
um anyways here's why you should date by
the way I I played I played Call of Duty
last night and I played this thing where
it's three guys we're on a team and we
have to do [__] together and it was two
guys that must have been friends and
they was talking to each other in
Spanish and I was so I was so bad that I
couldn't see or hear or understand they
were writing I couldn't understand any
of the words that they were saying other
than bot this is a bot he's so bad it's
a vamanos and they quit on me because I
was so bad just bought vamanos like
that's all that's not bad I remember I
got called a bot and I thought it was a
good thing because I was like oh Aimbot
I must be on like on lock that they're
calling me a bot and then I was like no
this is they're they're saying this is
like an NPC
all right so here let me do my bit here
here's how you should date a gamer
they're smart
they um you'll never have to worry about
where they are on a Friday night you
know they're just gonna be in the room
playing you know they're not at the club
they're not not doing anything
scandalous
um they'll fight for you should date a
gamer they'll they'll stand up for you
they're used to going to war on these
things
um they're easy to trick into doing
things because you just give them a
badge or a level or some sort of you
know Medallion and they'll just grind
for that for that prize uh they're tech
savvy they can set up your internet and
fix stuff when everything's broken
um and they'll always give you space if
you're the tempers that need space
they'll give you space but here's the
problem you may want to date a gamer
after that great sales pitch but the
problem is
there's no gamer dating app and that's
my idea I think there should be an app
for gamers to meet other Gamers here's
why this matters
wouldn't it be a sausage fest I mean how
many gamers are women all dating apps
for sausage fest that's the trick the
guys only see the girls the girls only
see the guys unless you switch the
settings right so it's like
um yes like all dating apps the ratio
will be 30 to one
that's that's expected uh but that's
that's normal for a dating app here's
why I think it's cool
um I think Gamers have a lot in common I
think gamers are a pretty big Market
there's hundreds and hundreds of
millions of Gamers out there like gaming
the gaming industry makes more than
money than Hollywood right so it's like
if you think people like movies people
like games more
um
but there's no easy way to meet a gamer
and if you meet a gamer you actually
have a lot of comment and you might have
things to do in common and so I think
one of the hard Parts about dating apps
is that they're all profiles
um and flirts and not really dates and
then a bunch of companies came in and
were like we're gonna get you on a date
um but then the reality was like getting
people out into the real world to go on
a date is kind of like really really
high friction and matching them was a
pain in the ass I did a bunch of those I
think that gamer dating would work
because you could be like cool you
matched you guys are both interested in
each other
and you might put you have some games in
common because that's part of your
profile what games you guys both like to
already play
go Squad up play again go play Call of
Duty together and in doing so you're
gonna be talking you're gonna be doing
something together it's like going
bowling or going puppet golf but just
more fun and so I think somebody could
this is a legit idea first I was gonna
save this for a drunk ideas episode
and then it kind of grew on me I was
like no no this could actually work like
if you think this can't work let me
remind you that there is a dating app
called Farmers Only
right there's there's dating apps called
Black People Meet and those are those
that work if you think those can work
and Gabriel dating can't work you're
nuts game-relating could definitely work
and it could definitely be big
definitely go sell it a match for like
75 million dollars in three years is
Farmers Only still a thing
uh you know I haven't checked in on a
little while but they used to run like
TV commercials yeah yeah you haven't
been keeping tabs they're like still
that looks very old yeah still paying
the hosting all right they're doing 700k
in monthly visits so not bad that's so
funny
um what's your name for it uh I don't
have one just yet yo working title TBD
um open to suggestions yeah I think it's
a pretty bad idea well I sold it pretty
hard so that's just funny
I mean maybe dude dating apps suck
that's the worst business there is man
because only like three or four of them
it's like a winner taking all Market you
know what I mean there's tons of dating
apps I mean who's the winner that took
all Tinder no what Bumble no uh batch
e-harmony nope okay Cupid no it's like
social media where it's like there could
be you know there's hundreds of social
media platforms but there's like four
that matter
um do you know what I mean I remember
when I was at Monkey Inferno a guy came
to the office getting KJ and he's like
I'm gonna make an Indian like you know
there's Jewish dating apps there's
farmer dating apps there's black people
dating apps I'm gonna make an Indian
dating app I was like all right that's a
good idea I guess and I was like do you
have any background on this he's like
I'm in the end and I'm trying to date
and he's like you know that's my
background I was like okay I guess super
qualified and then he's like um
he's like here's what we're gonna do
differently and he's like
I was like so what are the features like
what do you have to do to differentiate
he's like well I told you it's an Indian
dating app so the app's gonna say this
is for Indians trying to meet other
Indians
I was like oh he's right that is
actually the main feature is that you're
going to curate the people and sort of
filter for people who want to meet other
Indians for farmers who want to meet
other Farmers whatever for Jewish people
want to meet other Jewish people and so
I was like okay I guess that is already
better than Tinder if you're in any
person who wants to be an Indian because
you're going to get 100 hit rate here
versus maybe uh five percent hit rate on
a generic dating app and I was like okay
so how do you make money he's like do
you know how much people pay for dating
apps like the is it I'll do the same
business model I was like all right I'm
trying to poke holes but he's just got
it covered and I was like but how are
you gonna like I was like what do
Indians care about more than others he
goes oh that's where I'm gonna do
something different I'll go okay here it
is what's the big feature what's the big
Tech breakthrough he's like like your
mom is your like co-user you log in with
LinkedIn and I go what and he goes yeah
he's like because I don't know if people
know this like Indian culture it's like
a big deal of like uh there's like a
chat Indian people date on like a
checklist it kind of stems from like the
arranged marriage background where
literally you marry on a checklist you
know what the pickup line is for like I
have most of my friends are Indian
because you and Neville my best friend's
Indian the pickup line when you're
around other Indians is so what do you
do that's basically like
that's like what they do
yeah so basically he was like you're
gonna log in with LinkedIn so we know
that you have like a legit job and uh I
was like okay and then he's like yeah
that's like the main thing that you know
helps separate people you know I was
like whoa
um so he builds this app it's called
Bill Mill and he uh which means like
hearts mate
um how do you spell it d-i-l-m-i-l
who builds this app and I'm keeping
track of this guy and he uh
and sure enough he just starts going
into like all the niche communities
newsletters blogs YouTubers starts
promoting it running ads basically
saying hey if you're an Indian person
you're tired of striking out on dating
apps because Indian people have like
terrible success rates on Indian apps on
on normal dating apps I think Okay Cupid
said that like the worst like in the in
the free market of dating I think the
absolute worst was an Indian male second
a close second was like Chinese mail
um they were like the two least
desirable according to the OKCupid match
data that they've released and you know
what the highest was I think the highest
the most liked person I think was an
Asian woman yeah exactly I think it was
a Asian woman was was number one
um because they were getting all the
attention from the Asian guys and the
white guys I think it was like the the
data with what it showed is like they
get like it's like top preference
amongst two big user groups or something
and there's this like weird stereotype
that like uh Asian women are supposed to
be more submissive and dumb [__] like
that and I think that there's like some
weird like Kinks out there of of like a
true white guy
um I'm like no it's like men who have
happened really captured this like
mothers
so hey it's on the it's on Christian
Rudder wrote that blog post the founder
of Okay Cupid I think that's like the
whole thing their blog posts were great
that was a great strategy they had um
anyway so he whatever five years later
he sells this thing I think he sold it
for 75 or 100 million dollars to uh to
the match no way and they were like yeah
we match group is a collection of dating
apps we have our our generic catch-all
Mass Market apps Tinder
um uh and uh what's the other one um
Match.com and then they have like all
the niche apps and so they own like 20
dating apps or something like that and
so if you just fill one of those
verticals that they don't have a winner
in
um they'll buy you at like a preset
multiple and I was like wow that's
pretty impressive they paid 50 million
dollars for it I don't know man this guy
KJ he's pretty good looking and now he's
rich I think he I think he he's probably
doing anything they went up with him the
other day and he was like you didn't
believe and I was like I was like well
you're right I didn't believe and uh
actually sort of you know
when I didn't believe I really wanted to
be right I'm sorry about that I was kind
of rooting against you in a way but then
you proved me wrong and you were
absolutely right congratulations you did
a great job have have you seen the
Indian Netflix show where it's like your
parents are setting you up with like
this Matchmaker dude so at first I
thought that shit's the worst where uh
you know I'm like your parents are just
telling you what to do
but when you think about it it's kind of
like it's kind of like the uh Paradox of
choice right where they're just like
this is it this is the one you were
doing this uh you kind of are forced to
find happiness in that and it doesn't
seem actually maybe the worst arranged
marriages are they I have no idea are
they bad or is it kind of they can be
and they can't be I think the stats show
it's about the same divorce rate as in
America but what that doesn't show is
that any people don't get divorced they
like you know they're like we will
suffer in this unhappy marriage rather
than get divorced and be happy and but
have Society know that we failed at our
marriage or whatever whatever so I I
don't think there's a way to really know
how successful or unsuccessful it is uh
me and uh me and by the way a quick
indeed story it means Neville were out
to dinner with darmesh at HubSpot and
Neville was saying how he doesn't he's
like man India like that's where I'm
from and I go back there and it makes
you grateful to be in America because
like these guys got nothing and like
it's not very nice over there this and
that and he was like not insulting uh
like poor Indians but like saying like
it's like a pain in the butt to be in
that situation and darmaster was like
yeah that was me I was that guy I had
nothing and I came here uh we were I was
like one of those guys like we you know
we had nothing and uh they were all just
talking about India India sounds like a
wild place man
it just seems a lot of people describe
things like that because how do you uh
you know you can only agree with that
can't really disagree with X is a wild
place it's the same thing as our
business pitch of like it's this just
beautifully done we're just gonna do it
beautifully it's the same thing it's
like dude that's a wild place it's like
what the food the cult the crime what
are we talking about here's the story
you told the story you told is that when
your mom came to America I don't know if
you were joking or not you said tooth
except blew my mind you said the first
thing you said she she had never used
utensils you said that do you remember
saying that this is all blood record
you're like she didn't use utensils
that's what you told that's what you
said on that spot
um
you no I am not I'm not putting any
judgment here I am repeating what you
said the second thing you said you go
wait when she went to hang up the phone
she didn't know how to hang up the phone
so she just let it like hang on the
bathroom and it was a while to hear that
story that that was it was like it made
me love your mom is what it did she told
me the story it was unbelievable she's
like I got on the plane I'd never been
on a plane before my parents just
dropped me off at the airport I'm 17
years old
I've never been on a plane before don't
even know what a plane is really uh I
just get shuffled along I show somebody
my ticket they send me here send me
there okay I get on a plane and she's
like I think it's like a train that's
all I've ever seen as a train and so I'm
just thinking this is gonna be like a
train ride and she's flying like 14
hours tell her that it goes in there her
parents didn't know either they never
been on a train a plane either they were
just like this is how you get to America
and she was like okay didn't ask don't
ask too many questions and so she she's
like I you know plain seat belts are
kind of funky she's like I did it I just
like put it pushed it and I went in on
the first try somehow miraculously and
the person next to me looked at me was
like oh you've flown before and she's
like
I was like oh my God I don't even know
what I'm getting myself into no I have
no idea what I just did I have no idea
how I'll get this off and um whatever I
guess I have a few hours to figure out
how to unbuckle this by the time I need
to get off to at my stop so then for 14
hours you're flying and she stays awake
because she's like
I don't want to miss my stop and she's
like this thing's not stopping what's
going on she like doesn't know how
planes work it was crazy the whole thing
was insane doesn't that make you feel
soft your mom your mother is so much
more Brave than we are
it makes me feel uh incredibly lucky
that uh you know she did all the hard
stuff so that I don't have to do it yeah
shout out it's like a shout out mom bird
moms like chew food and then just spit
it in their baby's mouth so they don't
have to chew that's what I feel like she
did with life she's just like chewed
life for me and then spitted in my mouth
and I just have like the easy life
um and on that visual
[Laughter]
um all right well thank you that's the
Pod uh what is it mfmpod.com we got the
merch and then uh what What's the clip
website
uh clip clipmfm.com or just go to
YouTube and search my first million
clips and please subscribe that way
we'll have to like when there's 500
subscribers we don't have a lot of
incentive to do the work of cutting you
know picking the perfect Parts trimming
them down cutting them and titling them
and making them like available to you if
you don't have time to watch the full
episode or you want to share just the
best bit with somebody because you know
sharing an hour-long podcast with
somebody's like assigning some you know
asking somebody to help you move on
Saturday like it's just a tough ask but
sharing a clip is like doing somebody a
favor and so uh go subscribe to that
thing so that we
um yeah we're like motivated to get to
do that I want to see that thing grow
all right check it out that's the pod
[Music]